NUMBER ONE IS THE RACE FOR
PRESIDENT...
AND IN CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT 3...
AND IN CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
FOUR...
((DENISE VALDEZ))
AND IN THAT SUPREME COURT
RACE...
((DENISE VALDEZ))
THE REPUBLICANS ARE
GATHERED AT THE SOUTH POINT
GETTING THEIR RESULTS TONIGHT.
JOE MOELLER IS AT THEIR WATCH
PARTY RIGHT NOW..
JOE...
((JOE MOELLER))
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
LET'S LOOK AT THE STATEWIDE
BALLOT
QUESTIONS.
THESE WOULD ALL IMPACT
THE STATE CONTITUTION..
AND
WOULD ALL TAKE EFFECT NOVEMBER
24-TH IF THEY ARE PASSED.
QUESTION ONE TAKES THE
BOARD OF REGENTS..
A GROUP OF 13 ELECTED BOARD
MEMBERS THAT CONTROL BUDGETARY
AND POLICY DECISIONS FOR
INSTITUTIONS UNDER THE NEVADA
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION...OUT
OF THE STATE CONSTITUTION.
IT WOULD INSTEAD MAKE IT A
STATUTORY BODY, SUBJECT TO
CHANGE THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
THE MEASURE WOULD ESSENTIALLY
GIVE THE NEVADA LEGISLATURE MORE
CONTROL OVER THE STATE'S COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
QUESTION 2 TAKES LANGUAGE OUT
THAT SAYS MARRIAGE IS BETWEEN A
MAN AND WOMAN.
A YES ON QUESTION TWO RECOGNIZES
MARRIAGE AS BETWEEN COUPLES
REGARDLESS OF GENDER,
QUESTION THREE MAKES IT SO THE
STATE BOARD OF PARDONS MEETS
MORE OFTEN..
4 TIMES A YEAR,
INSTEAD OF TWO TIMES.
IT ALSO REMOVES WHAT IS
EFFECTIVELY A VETO POWER OVER A
PARDON BY THE GOVERNOR.
QUESTION FOUR ENSHRINES OUR
VOTING BILL OF RIGHTS INTO THE
CONSTITUTION.
THAT LISTS THINGS LIKE :MAKING
SURE YOU CAN VOTE IF YOU ARE
STILL IN LINE WHEN THE POLLS
CLOSE..
AND THE RIGHT TO VOTE WITHOUT
INTIMIDATION, THREATS, OR
COERCION...
11 VOTERS RIGHTS ARE LISTED ON
THIS QUESTION.
THERE IS NO QUESTION FIVE.
AND QUESTION SIX PUTS THE 50 BY
30 RENEWABLE ENERGY STANDARD
INTO THE STATE CONSTITUTION,
WHICH REQUIRES ELECTRIC
UTILITIES TO ACQUIRE 50 PERCENT
OF THEIR ELECTRICITY FROM
RENWABLE RESOURCED BY 2030.
((BRIAN LOFTUS))
THE DEMOCRATS ARE ALL
GATHERED AT SPRINGS PRESERVE
TO CHEER ON THEIR CANDIDATES.
AND THERE ARE SOME TIGHT RACES.
ORKO MANNA IS OUT THERE
SPEAKING TO PARTY LEADERS.
ORKO -- IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF
WATCH PARTY, RIGHT?
((ORKO MANNA))
BRIAN...
DIFFERENT IS AN UNDERSTATMENT.
I WOULDN'T REALLY CALL THIS A
WATCH PARTY.
IT'S MORE OF AN ELECTION NIGHT
EVENT -- THAT'S BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO SUPPORTERS HERE.
IT'S JUST BEEN DEMOCRATIC
POLITICANS BASICALLY TALKING TO
THE MEDIA FOR A FEW MINUTES EACH
-- AND PROMPTLY LEAVING.
THE STATE PARTY SAYS THIS IS THE
SET UP BECAUSE OF
CORONAVIRUS SAFETY PRECAUTIONS.
STILL...
THEY HOPE THE ENERGY THEY'VE
BEEN PUTTING INTO RECENT VOTER
MOBILIZATION AND CANVASSING
EFFORTS WILL TRANSLATE INTO A
WIN TONIGHT FOR JOE BIDEN -- AND
FOR NEVADA DEMOCRATS UP AND DOWN
THE TICKET.
((KIRSTEN JOYCE))
LET'S UPDATE YOU ON SOME OF THE
SCHOOL BOARD RACES..
THERE ARE
FOUR OPEN SEATS.
THESE ARE ALL NON PARTISAN
RACES...
SO YOU WON'T SEE A PARTY
ATTACHED TO THEM.
DISTRICT A INCLUDES HENDERSON AS
WELL AS LAUGHLIN
AND SEARCHLIGHT, LISA GUZMAN
AND LIBERTY LEAVITT BOTH HOPING
TO SUCCEED OUTGOING TRUSTEE
DEANNA WRIGHT..
<<LIZA GUZMAN IS ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NEVADA STATE EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION AND EXEC DIRECTOR OF
THE EDUCATION SUPPORT EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION, LIBERTY LEAVITT IS
A FORMER CLARK COUNTY TEACHER,
MAGNET COORDINATOR AND CENTRAL
OFFICE ADMINISTRATOR WHO NOW
WORKS FOR A LOCAL EDUCATION NON
PROFIT.>>
DISTRICT B WHICH COVERS MOAPA
VALLEY, AND A LARGE AREA OF
NORTH LAS VEGAS HAS CANDIDATES
JEFF PROFITT AND KATIE
WILLIAMS...
<<PROFITT SERVES ON THE BOARD OF
WORKFORCE CONNECTIONS,
INTERACTING WITH CCSD IN
ALIGNING CURRICULUM FOR THE
DISTRICTS CAREER AND TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
KATIE WILLIAMS..
A RECRUITER FOR THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD WORKED WITH HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS.
SHE HAS PLEDGE TO DONATE ALL HER
PAYCHECKS AS A TRUSTEE BACK TO
CCSD.
BOTOTHE WOMEN IN THE RUNNING
RIRIST C SEAT ARE PRODUCTS
THE COMMUNITY THEY HOPE TO
OVERSEE.
ELYN RA MORAL ADUATED
OM MOJAVE HIGH SCHOOLA
TAMEKA HENRY, FROM CHEYENNEIGH
SCHOOL.
BOTH LADIES HEPT THEIR
ULTS LIVES FOCUSED ON
PROVING EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
<<MORALES IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE FULLFILLMENT FDA NON
OFIT FOCUSED ONOLLEGE
CESS, AND HENRY HAS EN A
NGTIME ADVOCATE FOR HEAD
ART
STRICTE E, REPRESENTS THE
MRLIN AREA AS WELL AS MT.
ARLESTON AND INDIAN SPRINGS.
RRENTLY HOLDING E SEATS
LOLA BROOKS, THE ONLY INCUMBENT
AMONG ALL FOUR SCHOOL BOARD
RACES, SHE WAS FITLTED TO
E BOARD IN 2016 ANNAMED
PRESIDENT IN 2019.
R AENGER IS TEACHER ALEXIS
LT..
1YEAR VETERAN OF THE
STRICT AND THE ONLY CURRENT
AER IN THE RUNNING FOR
AT.SHE SAID SHE'S RUNNING TO
PROVIDE THAT TEACHER PERSPECTIVE
AND REFOCUS THE CONVERSATION ON
STUDENTS.
LET'S LOOK AT SOME
GISLATURE
CES...
))